among the various consequences that
follow from what has been said this one
in particular can be stressed that
knowledge is only actual and can only be
expounded as science or a system
furthermore that a so-called basic
proposition or principle of philosophy
if true is also false
just because it is only a principle it
is therefore easy to refute it the
refutation consists in pointing out its
defect and it is defective because it is
only the universal or principle it is
only the beginning
if the refutation is thorough is derived
and developed from the principle itself
not accomplished by counter assertions
and random thoughts from the outside the
refutation would therefore properly
consist in the further development of
the principle and in thus remedying the
defectiveness if it did not mistakenly
pay attention solely to its negative
action without awareness of its progress
and results on their positive side to
the genuinely positive exposition of the
beginning is thus also conversely just
as much a negative attitude towards it
that is towards its initially one-sided
form of being immediate or purpose it
can therefore be taken equally well as a
refutation of the principle that
constitutes the basis of the system but
it is more correct to regard it as a
demonstration that the basis or
principle the system is in fact only its
beginning
in 24 Hegel is saying that knowledge
only becomes actual when science
remember this in shaft disciplinary
knowledge structured knowledge becomes
system and he says that this is one of
the consequences that follows from from
what's been said he wants to stress this
and he says furthermore so-called basic
propositions or principles of philosophy
if true are also false they're true and
they're false at the same time now
that's an interesting thing to say and
that requires some mulling over what
what could he mean by that you know one
possibility would be to say well they're
true in one sense but false in another
sense or maybe they're true in that
they're true at a given point in time
but they cease being true later on they
become false because what they're
talking about has changed but would that
work for philosophy well I suppose it
would work for some things like if human
nature changes over time and your your
propositions are about human nature
what about physical reality hmm that's
that's that's a problem there what about
logic to the laws of logic change over
time you know from place to place the
pasta is pasta all right is truth on one
side of the Pyrenees falsity on the
other it's not so much that that he's
talking about he's talking about
something a bit deeper Hegel says and as
a basic proposition or as a principle
it's true but it's also false
it's assailable precisely because it is
a basic proposition and here you might
say well what the hell are we supposed
to build our philosophical systems out
of if not basic propositions and a you
would say yeah precisely the question
isn't whether you build on them or build
from them
it's how you build and how you
understand the process of building of
integration so he says it's very easy to
refute a principle because it's just a
principle the refutation consists in
pointing out its defect and it's
defective because it is only the
universal or a principle it is only the
beginning so there's all sorts of
principles where somebody will will you
know begin their philosophy with that
and somebody will come along and say oh
I've got a counterexample or you know
the word that they love these days I've
got a defeater for you Ian Hagen would
say and here he'd be like Aristotle
again you know so keep bringing up
Aristotle because Hegel is drawing a lot
from him he would say you know there are
going to be exceptions so you're really
being silly if you think that you're
going to refute a basic principle that
we're using to to work out something
more extensive by saying I've got an
objection to it and Hegel says the
objections generally come in two
different sorts they're a counter
assertion coming in from the outside
usually from somebody else's system I
don't accept your beginning points and
then so what beginning points do you
have
and their beginning points turn out to
be something completely arbitrary or you
know something that only makes sense
within their system you know this is the
case actually for a lot of people who
criticize Hegel where you know a popper
set about Hegel X Y Z well you know
maybe poppers right but wouldn't you
need to read the Hegel first to figure
that out maybe you shouldn't just come
in from the outside and and criticize
maybe you actually have to explore from
from within he also talks about random
thoughts people just come up with random
stuff you know I just don't accept that
it's you know they can be stubborn about
it and this doesn't appeal to me it
doesn't doesn't grip my feelings and
then you say well we're doing philosophy
here it's not just about whether it
feels good to you or something like that
and then you can come up with other
random thoughts as well so Hegel says
if you really want to refute a basic
proposition or principle what you have
to do is use it to refute itself if the
refutation is thorough it's derived and
developed from the principle itself not
accomplished by counter assertions they
have random thoughts coming in from the
outside the refutation would therefore
properly consist in the further
development of the principle and that
development is not just going to be you
know this process of becoming our area
that we've talked about mediation it's
also going to be when you put it
together with the other principles and
you weave them together into a system
it's from the perspective of the system
that you can say wow this basic
principle actually needs to be rethought
or we might have to get rid of this all
together this may actually have been a
good starting point but turns out that
we didn't really need it you know what
would be an example of that well think
about contemporary Aristotelian ism
Aristotle says a lot of really
boneheaded things about women and about
laborers and you're not going to find a
lot of contemporary rest Italians many
of whom are actually women saying yeah
Aristotle was dead-on about that that
you know distinction that he made
between men and women saying that women
were really just defective men and you
know could never be fully rational
couldn't develop the you know the
faculties as well this this basic
principle of gender difference in
Aristotle it is something that you from
the perspective the broader perspective
that an Aristotelian system provides you
you can say we've got good reason to
actually reject that one now if
Aristotle were around today still
working through his system he and he
were to sit down with him at the bar
he'd probably say yeah I think that one
was I was a bit off I was generalizing
too much from the society that I was
living in at the time in which gender
rules looked a lot like that maybe I
wasn't even right about that
you know I have to sort of
retrospectively think back to the women
that I knew in 4th century BC and figure
out whether I was actually correct the
point is that Hegel is getting at if you
want to refute a basic proposition if
you want to reveal the falsity in it you
have to do so by continually developing
so you have to you have to give it the
benefit of the doubt or you know the old
proverb give it enough rope to hang
itself you have to let it unfold so that
you can then say aha
here's where it's going wrong we have to
modify it we have to reject it it's
showing itself is untrue you know we can
think of a few other examples of this as
well you know they take Rene Descartes
if you want to criticize de cartes
hyperbolic doubt and his reliance on
that in the meditations and in some of
his other works which is really a key
element of his system what you have to
do is something along these lines you
and this is actually what Charles
somebody like Charles did with with
Descartes you have to go along with them
you can't just say well nobody really
does dealt like that or well you know in
my system we don't have we don't have to
doubt along those lines because we you
know we we believe in empirical reality
what you have to do is is follow along
with a cart and an outtake Arctic cart
you'd have to go along and say you know
once you've opened up this can of worms
with doubt which is really a cute I mean
that's what's going on in that in the
juncture between this the first and the
second meditation he's got that metaphor
of the slave which you know is is really
quite important it's overlooked there's
one of his weak points if he can't pull
off providing some sort of certainty
after doing this hyperbolic doubt then
all you've got is doubt and yet that
can't be the case
so if you go along with this you can
come up with reasons why from an
internal Cartesian perspective there
might be something hinky with this this
idea of doubt and it's resolution that
Descartes has but you can only do that
if you do the work of developing that
within the system
you can't just come out from the outside
and say well I don't believe in doubt
like that or that's no good for me
because that's not really a response not
a valid response according to Hegel so
he says the refutation consists in the
further development of the principle and
in remedying the defectiveness if it did
not mistakenly pay attention solely to
its negative action without awareness of
its progress and result on their
positive side - it turns out maybe
sometimes with these basic propositions
we say well we're assuming that they're
true but then they're going to show up
to be false but maybe they actually
within the system they turn out to have
a deeper truth to them you know let's
use another example is there such a
thing as human nature and if so is it
social or are we primarily a social and
then have to be socialized so you could
say with somebody like Aristotle man is
a social animal right that's a basic
proposition which he spends quite a bit
of time working out the the
ramifications and implications of but
doesn't really bring to a complete
conclusion because we hadn't seen all
the societies of the time he did quite a
comprehensive review unfortunately lost
most of what he wrote on that all these
constitutions but maybe he was wrong
maybe he was wrong to think that our
nature is inherently social that the
political community is something that is
natural to us do we then swing over to
the other extreme and become say
Hobbesian individual
this or you know individualist some
other stripes no not necessarily because
maybe he's right on a deeper level maybe
if you actually you know work through
politics book one you see that what he
means by us being social animals is that
we have the capacity to signify and to
make present for ourselves moral values
and that the Koinonia the commonalities
the sharings and these are what bring us
together
that this isn't in a certain way more
basic than the notion of the polis
that's a possibility
all right I don't want to get too much
in the Aristotle here because we're
talking about Hegel but that would be an
example of what he's talking about here
so he says the genuinely positive
exposition at the beginning is thus also
just as much a negative attitude towards
it when we're working out the system and
we have these beginnings in basic
propositions we are taking a negative
attitude towards them by insisting that
they be able to speak to us that they be
able to work themselves out show
themselves through examples overcome
whatever failings they seem to have
answer counter objections coming from
from the outside and be able to make
sense of them and weave themselves into
the fabric of a system we are treating
them both positively and negatively at
the same time we are treating them as
both false and true at the same time by
weaving them into a system of truth
that the true is actual only as system
or that substance is essentially subject
is expressed in the representation of
the absolute as spirit the most sublime
notion and the one which belongs to the
modern age and it's religion
the spiritual alone is the actual its
essence or that which has being in
itself it is that which relates itself
to itself in is determinant it is other
being and being for self and in this
determinate nests or in its self
externality abides within itself in
other words it is in and for itself but
this being in and for itself is at first
only for us or in itself it is spiritual
substance it must be also this for
itself it must be the knowledge of the
spiritual and the knowledge of itself as
spirit that is it must be an object to
itself but just as immediately as a
sublated object reflected into itself it
is for itself only for us insofar as its
spiritual content is generated by itself
but insofar as it is also for itself for
its own self it is self generation the
pure notion is for it the objective
element in which it has its existence
and it is in this way in its existence
for itself and object reflected into
itself the spirit that so developed
knows itself as spirit is science
science in its actuality and the realm
which it builds for itself in its own
element
in Section 25 we've now arrived at a
really critical juncture where Hegel is
laying some cards on the table and
showing us the absolute idealism that he
is endorsing he says that all of what
was said so far that the true is actual
only a system or that substance is
essentially subject these key ideas that
he's been working out that he's been
exploring that he's been arguing for
these are expressed in the
representation that's a key term that
we're going to get back to of the
absolute he has spirit he goes on and he
says this is the most sublime notion and
the one which belongs to the modern age
and to religion and those are really key
critical points as well let's actually
dwell on that first right after we
actually talk a little bit about what
what spirit means and I suppose this is
something where I should have brought
this up from the beginning so German has
this term Geist and that's why you're
going to find more than one translation
or more than one term used in the titles
of these translations this is called the
phenomenology of spirit it's also called
the phenomenology of mind and French has
a similar term in Esprit which can mean
spirit and it can also mean mind and it
can actually also mean in French it has
a slightly wider significance it can
mean wit so mind or spirit when we talk
about the spiritual and the mental
they're not different things for
somebody like Hegel
we tend to dissociate those in English
in part because we have different terms
that we use for each of these in German
it's it's the same term and that allows
an interesting interplay between the two
of those same thing with with with
French
spirituality is not something that's
completely divorced from the mentals of
the notion of a purely effective
spirituality is kind of a degenerate
form for for this this way of looking at
things so he says it's the most sublime
notion and here you know notion in the
term of concept its characteristic of
the modern age now you might say what
the hell modern age is Hegel talking
about sure isn't ours well you know
Hegel is writing at a time where it
looks like a lot of progress has been
continually made got to remember the
French Revolution is still for all
practical purposes ongoing at the time
that he's writing this Europe has been
has been developing and developing and
developing the masses now I actually had
the possibility of the life that won't
just be misery and ignorance and bigotry
and superstition the Republic of Letters
has been established and it's still
ongoing even through the Napoleonic Wars
there's this conception that he's god of
history as reaching a sort of
culmination point where the spiritual
where the ideal where the mental becomes
more important and explicitly more
important than the merely corporeal or
physical or purely economic or purely
you know pick whatever you like purely
pragmatic so that's something that he
sees as characteristic of modernity not
all of modernity but it becomes a real
live possibility in the modern age it's
also something that is associated with
religion spirituality why because
religion for Hegel is how we approach
the absolute that which transcends us
and
encompasses us and perhaps even redeems
us and and guides us towards a greater
amount of being what we are
reveals to us our true purposes all of
that is spirituality Spirit working
through through the world now I
mentioned this this term representation
and he's not going to dwell on this here
in German it's it's a forced Elam and
this is going to turn out to be a really
important term when we get to talking
about religion which is the penultimate
part of the phenomenology Hegel thinks
that religion is like one step short of
philosophy and in many respects if we
want to talk about other kinds of
philosophy it's one step short his
philosophy and it's even better than a
lot of philosophies available at the
time it gets to the heart of things it
gets to the real true essence of things
more reliably than other modes of
thought other modes of being but it
doesn't go all the way its penultimate
for triangle and its penultimate because
it works through representations one of
the the thrusts the constant you know
criteria and measures for the
phenomenology is are we still working
with a representation or have we arrived
at the point where we have conceptual
knowledge we want conceptual knowledge
from hails perspective not just
representations because representations
although there are very important steps
and they our progress are still
contingent they're there they're
culturally conditioned they are focused
in in certain respects and they can
sometimes mislead us so Hegel will say
the spiritual alone is the actual only
the spiritual is truly real the material
the humdrum day to day corporal
pragmatics that's it's not to say that
that's not real but it's given its
you'll meaning its truth by the
spiritual by what lurks behind it by
what inhabits it and breathe life into
it so he says the spiritual alone is
essence or that which has being in
itself but it's also that which relates
itself to itself so that makes it being
for itself as well as being in itself
we've talked a lot about this process so
I'm not going to like draw more circles
or spirals or or you know write
reflection on the board one more time
because we that's all sort of built into
this notion of for itself he says it is
that which relates itself to itself so
remember this this process of mediation
of splitting of doubling becoming other
to itself is part of that because of
this it is determinate that's a key
thing I will put on the board spirit
takes on determinacy here's ye --gel
would actually reject people who say
yeah I'm spiritual but I am not really
religious you know that that whole
notion there it's too vague as a matter
of fact spirit can be political spirit
can be legal spirit can be artistic but
spirit takes place through determinacy
it's not just something abstract it
becomes other it becomes for itself by
being something by being something
determinate so you know for the ancient
Greeks the realm of spirit is going to
take place in part through their
sculpture and part through their plays
in part through the organization of
democratic polity z-- and the fight
against the oligarchs and the the you
know revelation that that Demick the
democracy actually can lead to tyranny
and empire on the part of the Athenians
all of that is is part of spirit and all
that is deter
so we actually have to pay attention to
real things and find the greater hidden
associative meaning that they possess we
have to see the spirit working through
them Hegel would say that's all part of
spirit being for itself spirit posits
itself to be more than just being in
itself so that he says in this
determinate nests or it itself
externality it abides within itself in
other words it is in and for itself it's
not just being in itself not just being
for itself it is also the unity or the
fusion of those two but here's where it
gets really really interesting then he
says this being in and for itself is at
first only for us or in itself it is
spiritual substance it must be also this
for itself it must be the knowledge of
the spiritual and the knowledge of
itself as spirit it must become object
to itself but just as immediately
reflected into itself it is for itself
only for us so this for us and I put an
exclamation point after shows up twice
it's being in itself is also it's being
for us the development of Spirit of God
however you want to put it through
history through human agency is for us
the human beings that are actually
observing and perhaps even wondering at
this process spirits dynamic activity
its own reflection into itself is also
what it is because it's for us we are
part of the process a lot of times
people get turned off by Hegel because
they think yeah you know we're all just
like you know moments in the process we
our individuality doesn't really make
here's a more optimistic view on this
know we do matter and not just as single
nodes to be you know sublated or washed
away or you know overcome in our
identity spirit matters because it
exists for us otherwise you know let it
happen all over there it exists for us
now that doesn't mean that you know we
can just approach it uncritically and
without expecting to be transformed
ourselves in the process that you know
we're qualified right off the bat to to
pass a media judgments on this whole
process or its plausibility but it does
mean that we're being invited to join in
the dance so to speak
so he says insofar as it is also for
itself for its own self this self
generation the pure notion is for itself
the objective element in which it has
its existence and in this way it's an
existence in itself is an object
reflected into itself that the spirit
that so devout knows itself as spirit
how does it know itself as spirit
partly through you know this entire
process that has preceded us where
spirit has become conscious of itself
partly through us in the present partly
through Hegel partly through us so he
says spirits so developed knows itself
as spirit that's how it becomes science
science in its actuality has to be
spirit put into another way in order for
philosophy to truly become knowledge to
truly become science to truly become
what Hegel's calling this in shaft sort
of systematic disciplinary rigorous form
of knowing it has to do so through
coming to know itself there is no such
thing for Hegel as spiritless sign